We had part one of this next story yesterday
and now it's actually gotten even more
interesting. Right wing propaganda network
Newsmax has now been forced to debunk its
own election lies due to a legal threat from
the voting machine company Smartmatic, which
both demanded a retraction and reserved
its right to take legal action. Yesterday,
I told you that after six weeks of spreading
all sorts of debunked lies about election fraud,
Lou Dobbs on Fox aired a clarifying
segment saying basically none of that
stuff I said was true. Newsmax has now done
the exact same thing. So let's take a look at
this is anchor John Tobacco. That's
his real name, as far as I know,
issuing clarifications. And the title of this
clip should really be We don't want to get sued.
Since Election Day, various guests, attorneys
and elected officials have appeared on Newsmax
and offered opinions and claims about Smartmatic
and Dominion systems. Both companies that offer
voting software in the U.S. and Newsmax would like
to clarify its news coverage and note that it has
not reported as to certain claims made about these
companies. There are several facts our viewers and
readers should be aware of. Newsmax has found
no evidence that either Dominion or Smartmatic
owns the other or has any business association
with each other. We have no evidence that Dominion
uses Smartmatic software or vice versa. No
evidence has been offered that dominicano
Smartmatic use software or reprogramed software
that manipulated votes in the 2012 election.
Smartmatic has stated that its software was
only used in the 2020 election in Los Angeles,
was not used in any battleground state contested
by the Trump campaign. Newsmax has no evidence to
the contrary. Dominion has stated that the company
has no ownership relationship with the Pelosi.
Namely, the Feinstein family, the Clinton family,
Hugo Chavez or the government of Venezuela.
Neither Dominion nor Smartmatic has
any relationship with George Soros.
Smartmatic is a US company and not owned by the
Venezuelan government, Hugo Chavez or any foreign
official or entity. Smartmatic states that it has
no operations in Venezuela, while the company did
election projects in Venezuela from 2004 to 2017
and state it was never founded by Hugo Chavez,
nor did it have a corrupt relationship with him
or the Venezuelan government. For more on this,
please go to our website at Newsmax Dotcom.
If that isn't a guy being held hostage by the
company's lawyers, I don't know what is.
So just like with yesterday's Fox clip,
the Newsmax anchor says there's no connection
between Smartmatic and Dominion. Votes weren't
manipulated by the voting machines. The machines
in question weren't used in battleground states.
There's no connection to Nancy Pelosi or
Hugo Chavez or the Clintons or Venezuela.
George Soros has nothing to do with this. And
it's really quite stunning. And just like I said
yesterday, lots of the Newsmax audience will hear
this, but they're not going to believe it because
they will believe that the Newsmax host was forced
to do this, which he was essentially because of
the legal demand letter that was received. But
I'll actually even go further. How do you make up
for five weeks of spreading disinformation, seven
weeks almost at this point, hundreds of times
with this one segment? This is The Lou Dobbs
segment, similar to what we just saw, Newsmax.
This was yesterday on Fox Business. Take a look.
Lots of opinions about the integrity of the
election, the irregularities of mail in voting
of election voting machines and voting software.
One of the companies is Smartmatic. And we
reached out to one of the leading authorities
on open source software for elections,
Eddie Perez, for his insight and views.
Eddie is the global director of tech development
at the Open Source Election Technology Institute.
We ask him for his assessment of Smartmatic
and recent claims about the company.
Have you seen any evidence that
Smartmatic software was used to
flip votes anywhere in the U.S. in this election?
I have not seen any evidence that Smartmatic
software was used to delete, change, alter
anything related to vote tabulation.
Smartmatic says its software was never
used outside of L.A. County in twenty twenty.
Do you know whether or not that's true?
That is my understanding. Smartmatic
functioned as the contract manufacturer
for the Los Angeles County voting system, and that
was a customized system that was effectively built
to the county's order. I am not aware of them
having any other direct customers relationships
with election officials in the United States.
What about Smartmatic and Dominion? Do you know
if they're related, whether one owns the other,
whether Dominion uses Smartmatic software?
Both Dominion and Smartmatic have
individually and respectively put out
very clear statements from their corporate
headquarters, each of them indicating they
are independent companies. They are not
related to each other. It is my understanding
that neither one of them has an ownership
stake in the other or anything like that.
So almost identical information is being
conveyed in the two videos. Clearly, they don't
want to face the lawsuits that they were being
threatened with, but I just don't know how one,
two minute fact check once makes up for spreading
this stuff for going on two months. But of course,
they're doing the absolute minimum to either avoid
being sued or to mitigate damage if indeed they
are sued. That's all they care about. Now, here's
a bonus clip for you. This is this is great.
Host Sebastian Gorka is interviewing
the My Pillow guy, Mike Lyndell
and Mike Lyndell starts going into the voter fraud
conspiracies and Saib Gorka actually cuts him off
because he clearly has been advised. We
can't keep repeating this stuff. Take a look.
I believe in this president and I'll tell you why
nobody realized what a miracle we had on election
night at 11, 15. You know, you talked about
all this fraud, Doctor. The the the biggest
fraud is the Dominion machines.
And at 11, 15 on election night,
our great president, because I don't want to
discuss why we're not we're not going to get
into the minutia of the details. I want to
ask you, because this show is about courage.
So, Sibghatullah, they're desperate to get away
from that topic before they end up with another
legal threat. So the headlines go on the
front every day for six weeks and then they
put a correction on the back page once. That's
the equivalent of what they're doing here. Fox
News was told in the letter from the Smartmatic
lawyers, you need to claim there wasn't fraud
with the same amount of frequency and intensity as
the number of times you claimed there was fraud.
Clearly, Fox News hasn't done that.
Clearly, Newsmax hasn't done that for now.
But my concern is less legal than it is about the
reality that the damage has been done by their
harping on this stuff for six weeks. They may get
sued anyway because their lies were so egregious.
But the problem is that when you
do this for six or seven weeks,
the correction is irrelevant. You're not going
to change any of your own audience's mind because
they understand that you were clearly forced to
do this and that what you said for six weeks is
the truth as they see it will again have to do the
same. I don't know. We're keeping an eye on that.
But this is already a sign that, as
I've been saying for several weeks now,
the right wing media landscape for the next
several years is going to be very interesting,
regardless of what Donald Trump does.
And we'll be following it. And we'll have more
of these clips on The David Pakman Show Instagram
page, which you can find at David Pakman,